i'd like to
start today's episode off on a very
serious note it is
may 28th 2021 and five years ago
there was a very serious moment that
kicked off
all of this conflict all the fighting
and all the hatred
something that happened in this country
that just tore people apart at their
core
it's the killing of harambe five years
ago today i just posted about it they
they they took they they took our boy
and from that everyone just
erupted in rage no one could understand
the pain the grief was so intense
that we've been fighting ever since
r.i.p harambe
[Laughter]
i missed harambe you know when you're
you know you know when you're kids
sometimes you're like you're in in
elementary school or grade school and
like you miss a day
and then it's it just happens to be a
crucial day yeah yeah
five years ago today you're like sitting
i have no way eating a burrito
i was unplugged from this and then um
and then everybody's talking about
harambe
if you can explain to me in two or three
sentences harambe
gorilla who the the zoo he had a little
boy fell in
yeah and he was like dragging him so
they shot and killed him
yeah yeah and they became harambe was
the the young
the gorilla who's gorilla the gorilla
okay so they shot the gorilla to say the
little boy
got it and everyone was like it became a
meme they took our boy
you know harambe and it's been five
years everybody must produce the song
about it
it's true highly recommend very true
checking that one out
uh no i do feel bad about you know this
this gorilla being killed you know
it it it's still sad but it's a meme so
hey everybody thanks for hanging out it
was uh
it was not really a serious opening but
i wonder i wonder if people are
genuinely offended by like don't you
dare
insult the memory whose fault was it was
it the gorilla or the little boy
you know the boy fell in a human falls
in a gorilla cage the gorilla mauls the
human
they kill the gorilla whose fault was it
this would happen today
wouldn't you see an expose of the little
boy i mean wouldn't the media try to
destroy this kid's life
yeah i guess you know his parents that
mean everything yeah
this unarmed gorilla was killed by the
authorities right
i mean do we know anything about the kid
yeah yeah what was the kid doing
was there even a kid was the kid like
skulking around looking all
like peacocking he was trying to steal
you know from harambe's house
he's only three harambe was just
defending himself well the kid was three
yeah yeah okay oh okay yeah so he
doesn't he doesn't even
even remember he can't blame the kids
but let's get into the this the serious
story uh this one's risky
you know i it gave me pause looking at
this news because i'm like well youtube
might
absolutely ban us um we've got reporting
out that there's just a study suggesting
or
without saying that the covid was made
by china made by them and that after the
lab leak
they panicked and retro engineered it to
try and make it seem like it was
naturally occurring now
the only reason it's being reported by
the daily mail it's like a front page
story
maybe it's not true uh of course this is
a newsguard certified source so
i'm not going to ignore a breaking story
even if youtube punishes us for it but
the other thing is fauci himself said
that he wasn't convinced it was
naturally occurring if it's not
naturally occurring
then what does that mean if it emerged
next to the wuhan lab fauci is the one
who opened the door for this
conversation so
so be it we need to talk about it and uh
we'll talk about much stuff it's friday
we we take things easy
we we chill pretty much on friday and uh
uh we're being joined today by
national security analyst author dave
reboy david raboy
you wanna introduce yourself real quick
sure i um i tweet
at daveraboy.com i oh well i i
at daverboy i have a website at
daverboy.com
where i've got writing i write about
music i write about politics
uh international affairs and the
collapse of this country and the
collapse
of the country because this is you know
we're in a
civilizational crisis period and you
know that's on the menu
uh i have this book called qatar's
shadow war that i wrote where which
is available uh on the on the site or on
amazon or wherever very cool
cool talk about it and uh and yeah we
can talk about it right on great to be
here
this guy this guy ian is sitting here
what up home yes yeah okay what's going
on with ian's camera i don't know what's
giving me static you look like yesterday
give me the skinny
you look just like you did yesterday
which is actually an issue because i'm
pretty sure something's going on with
your camera
table the elements what's up yeah we
can't see you at all
what is happening today this camera is
just frozen i tried it
i've been running around the studio like
a crazy person all right you you you
um i think let me let me let me try
let's see let's see if tim can
magically fix it anyway i'm also here in
the corner
yeah we're chilling i'll tell you a
little story oh boy there was a frog
and uh he was having a hard time in the
in the woods so he ended up uh
meeting this other frog and the two of
them went off and they uh
you got it figured out it's still frozen
yeah it's just frozen w
t f ian your magnetic force is too much
i'll listen for a while and uh sorry you
want to switch chairs yeah sure actually
yeah that could work
all right we're gonna wing it guys it's
friday is the other camera on i'll turn
it on
it's funny because like you hear ian
talking there's like a still of him just
like in a weird face well i do have news
we have
upgrades coming so that computer we
ordered months ago is finally getting
put together
and hopefully we'll get it and uh you
know
all right let's rebuild let's see if
we're going to be ian can we see
there he is
oh there it is hello everyone oh my gosh
we'll get there eventually
good to be here oh all right yeah ian is
here let's go get this plasma ball
charged and cool
you got to plug it in so uh for those
that are that are wondering we've had a
ton of lingering issues after the power
went out
so we had a really bad storm knocked all
the power out and then everything kind
of got frazzled
but uh you know whatever you'd you'd
think we'd be professionals at this
point but uh
this looks like a professional outfit to
me it looks it's like almost there
it's like halfway there it looks like it
but we were we're winging it half the
time
semi-pro we just got an av guy to like
set compression and we've been doing the
show for over a year like a year and a
half yeah
everyone's like the sound is bad it's
like we'll figure it out
we'll get there we'll be fine it's fine
yeah i sure can i can turn you up man
all right everybody hey um how's that
ian before we get started
nothing yet go to timcast.com
sign up become a member and you'll get
access to exclusive
content in our members only area we were
hanging out lauren chen yesterday
look at that we got jack murphy we got
lauren chen you guys both love
you love them both and we were talking
about the black lives matter uh founder
quitting
so if you want to get this content go to
the site become a member but uh here's
the thing
when you're a member you're helping
support our work and that money goes
into hiring more people we're a couple
weeks out from
bringing on our own newsroom i bring
journalists we're taking pictures for
movies for shows
we're gonna be doing a whole bunch of
stuff and building up this big network
it takes time though because we got to
hire a lot of people and
quality control man is very difficult
but i'll tell you what if you really
really like
what we do and you think what we say is
important whether we're right or wrong
if you agree with the conversation
at least and if you really agree with
the message
share this video share this podcast we
don't have a big marketing
department like you know cnn but they
get hundreds of millions of views per
month because
the system is rigged youtube will put
them on the front page
everybody hates it but they do it and
then people share that stuff so
we gotta push back that's how you do it
but you know you can buy people's books
you can buy books from people like dave
or boy the uh
cutters shadow war or you know books
from people like michael malus or
michael knowles
he's gotta be active you got to throw it
throw uh throw some skin in the game
but let's let's talk about the story
that's going to get us in trouble
here we go exclusive from the daily mail
they say covet 19 at quote has no
credible natural ancestor
and was created by chinese scientists
who then tried to cover their tracks
with
quote retro engineering to make it seem
like it naturally arose from bats
explosive new study claims
they say these the study uh researchers
found
unique fingerprints and covered 19
samples they say could only have arisen
from manipulation in a laboratory now
i will stress we've already heard this
last year
and you had that one guy luke what's his
i can't remember his name he's a famous
virologist won the nobel peace prize
said the same thing they called him a
crackpot they called him a conspiracy
theorist
we've heard similar things before we're
hearing it again and the weirdest thing
right now is a bunch of journalists that
are like there's no evidence lab leak is
real there's all the evidence that it
was
natural zoologic you know transfer or
whatever and i'm like
all right let me let me let me break
down all y'all for where for uh let me
let me break down where we're at so far
okay i'm going to start with the
timeline as we know it now
not what's the timeline of the reporting
u.s provided funding to eco health
alliance money from that
fund from that pool went to the wuhan
lab for what's called gain of function
research where they tried to
make viruses gain functions the idea is
that by making a virus stronger
we'll understand it before it emerges in
the wild
so that's happening then around november
2019 some people got sick
videos came out reports came out
suggesting that at some point
people had been bitten by a bat or bats
had peed on somebody
so then a few months later we start
getting reports of the sickness emerging
in wuhan
it starts spreading and then we start
getting speculation
that it's from the wet market across the
street
from the wuhan lab already people are
asking questions could it have emerged
and you know i said often
you know look it's a background a virus
people in a wet market are it's
unsanitary actually i would i would
argue
that makes more sense simply because a
bio lab still has security a wet market
doesn't
so if i if i if you told me to put a
hundred bucks then i'd be like the place
with no security why would i bet on the
place with security but then when you
factor in
the fact that they were doing gain of
function research on bat corona viruses
when you when you factor in that people
were getting sick everything starts to
line up now we got fauci himself saying
he's not convinced it occurred naturally
and then we get the story
they go on to say daily mail exclusively
obtained a 22
page paper authored by the british
professor angus
dalgleich and norwegian scientist dr
berger sorensen
set to be published in the quarterly
review of biophysics discovery
the studies show that there's evidence
to suggest chinese scientists created
the virus
while working on a gain of function
project at the wuhan lab
gain of function research which was
temporarily outlawed in the us involves
altering
naturally occurring viruses to make them
more infectious
in order to study their potential
effects on humans
according to the paper chinese
scientists took a natural coronavirus
backbone
found in chinese cave bats and spliced
onto it
a new spike turning it into the deadly
and highly transmissible covet 19.
the researchers who concluded that kova
19 has no credible natural ancestor
also believe scientists reverse
engineered versions of the virus
to cover up their tracks quote we think
that there have been retro-engineered
viruses created
doll glace told dailymail.com they've
changed the virus
then tried to make out it was a sequence
years ago
the study also points to deliberate
destruction concealment or contamination
of data
in chinese labs and notes that
scientists who wish to share their
findings
haven't been able to do so or have
disappeared now that's where it gets a
little weird
that i'd like to read about that because
it sounded conspiratorial
until recently most experts have
staunchly denied the origins of the
virus were anything other than naturally
uh natural infection leaping from
animals to human earlier this week dr
anthony fauci defended us
funding of the wuhan institute of
virology saying the 600 000
grant was not approved for gain of
function research and i also want to
make sure we absolutely stress
fouchy bombshell as reported by the
hill.com not convinced
covet 19 developed naturally outside
wuhan lab
take just take that quote from fauci all
right we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna sit here we're gonna say i don't
know about this study
maybe the study is not true i don't know
all right youtube's banned people for
less
but fauci said he's not convinced it
developed naturally outside the lab
if the first reported cases were from
outside the lab
but it didn't develop naturally outside
the lab then it stands to reason
the lab leak hypothesis is true and it
was manufactured in the lab or
unless fouchy's wrong again it developed
naturally in the lab
how does it develop naturally in a lab i
don't know
the moment they put the virus in the lab
let's say let's say they found the virus
in a bat
and they put the bat in the lab and they
put the bat in a
in a box and then the virus mutates
that's that's that's lab engineered
they changed the conditions of the bat
that's the bare minimum for me i suppose
look this is a tremendous horrible
horrible slander
of the wet market community i mean it is
and i mean imagine the guy who owns that
wet market is it one man
is one guy i don't know maybe he's the
one guy who subleases to all the other
there's wet marketeers
did you see that new york times reporter
who said that lab leak was racist
sure yeah of course well no i mean
what's more racist lab league or wet
market exactly
so it's it's that that's what's funny so
uh the reporter for the new york times
who's covering covet tweeted
that one day we'll we'll stop talking
about lab league and discuss the racist
origins or whatever
and then people were like the wet market
is more racist
you know like the lab is plausible in
that people labs have accidents could
happen but then to accuse the chinese
people of having these filthy
disease-ridden markets
well it's because we eat bats i mean
yeah but did they really i thought that
was like an urban legend
or like a myth that they were eating
bats like people were saying bat soup
and then i guess
what are you selling what are you
selling live bats for at a wet market
i don't know i mean this is all this is
all you know coming from
media reports and you know all that all
that nonsense that uh that came out in
initially you know we heard about the
wet market we heard about the bats and
you know people joking about bat soup
and all this stuff and
and of course then the media backlash oh
my god all this is racist
yeah so so don't talk about it it's all
racist
it's it's the weirdest thing uh and i
guess it's because they hated trump
and trump suggested it so then all of a
sudden they had to i think it's a
combination of
of that trump says something they must
say the opposite but i also i also think
that politically they saw it as a way to
go after trump
if this was a natural phenomenon it's
trump's fault and then they can
they can they can use that to get trump
out think about this though
we we haven't we have an idea that the
media is getting less powerful
as alternative media rises
i i thought that for a couple of years i
thought that it was
declining in power and what kovid showed
me was that these guys
are still insanely powerful i mean think
about this
we have the biggest story in the world
everyone is hysterical afraid of
this virus and yet we're like a year on
and we're only now starting to think hey
where had this thing happened
i mean right in what world is that you
know 9 11 happens
immediately as soon as as the rubble is
is cleared no not even not even you know
the the the i was in new york the uh
the sky is full of clouds it's like all
right who did it
right how'd this happen who did it and
for this
we we go a year and and and it's not
just the media though
clearly the media is a component of an
establishment power
uh that's they they either because they
are pressured by each other they're
scared of of
being ostracized cnn says something
youtube says that's the truth we decided
we if cnn says that it's true and so you
go on youtube and you make some claims
at the election
they'll ban you you make some claims
about cove they'll ban you but for four
years
the media could go on youtube and make
the most outrageous
nonsensical claims about donald trump
and it was totally acceptable
sure so yeah i i you know i'll tell you
this i've made the point that
uh social media has empowered the
individual
but but like i stated in in the opening
when i was doing the promo spot
cnn gets hundreds of millions of views
on youtube why because youtube
guarantees that if you search for news
they will send you cnn
it's not just that they've decided cnn
is the truth they've decided it's the
only thing you're allowed to watch
so how do we combat that people just got
to keep
talking talk as much as you can i guess
and it's even worse than that because
you've got an entire industry now that
has developed
the you know the let's say the so-called
disinformation industry
which is really just a mutation of the
old countering violent extremism
um industry during the uh the the war on
terror it's basically the same people
oh yeah they've retooled themselves and
they've created
metrics and all kinds of justifications
for saying
no cnn is authoritative but tim poole
isn't is you know disinformation well so
they actually google told me i could
become authoritative if i chose to do it
if there's a process you go through
you have to like fill out forms and then
submit something and then they put you
in their authoritative list
so it's possible uh the the challenge is
that
it's it's an obvious institutional bias
so
i do believe youtube likes me more than
other channels
i do because you get a lot of views
maybe uh
but i i certainly think that you know
there are smaller channels
that are still decently sized that have
gotten strikes for saying similar things
to me
and you know we're running a risk here
simply talking about the story because
youtube
they go nuts i mean crowder cited the
cdc data and they nuked him
right so well i mean i also think that
you've got such
you've created such a nice
serious infrastructure around the show
with you know with the house and the
equipment and the team and everything i
mean
that i think that for
youtube and some of these you know no
let's just say for youtube
they look at this and they say this is
this is a story that we want
told right right we want someone like
tim poole to be able to make a living
and to thrive on this platform makes
sense yeah it's not a because
if you if you get you know you get
yanked
and you get banned that's a big story
right and it's been it's bad for
business it's bad for me youtube is a
very dangerous place to run a business
facebook is a very dangerous place to
run a business and
if if so actually youtube did a survey
they said they sent me this uh
everybody got it probably if you're a
youtuber and it's like fill out our
survey and it asks me questions about
what platforms i use
and i'm like i use you know twitter
instagram tic tac whatever
and then it's like how how do you feel
about them how confident are you and i'm
just like oh not at all like
twitter like do you feel safe using no
way
do you think they have your best
interest absolutely not and then for
youtube i'm like
youtube is definitely not a safe place
for a business it does provide an
opportunity for reach
and for for revenue but youtube could
ban you at any moment without notice and
they've done it before
they did it to a guy named monkey jones
he had no strikes
he broke no rules and they deleted all
of his channels without warning
because they were they found his content
distasteful that was it
he broke no rules he just made it it was
it was black comedy
and they didn't like it he did he uh
i'll leave it there it's
it's spicy comedy but it wasn't racist
it was just it was like the edge of edgy
and they deleted his channel outright so
this is this is the world we live in
right now where of course youtube wants
people to believe
you can be a creator so long as you
follow these rigid guidelines we don't
explain to you
i mean we will change at any moment
right we just learned this is really
interesting from project veritas too
i don't know if you saw this where they
had the whistleblower come out and they
say that
publicly facebook's guidelines are very
vague
internally they're extremely well
defined
and they do that so that way when they
ban someone they can oh
well you know this rule is violated for
this reason and they can just
make it whatever they want right so i
mean twitter's the same
twitter operates exactly the same way
that i i was a few years ago
i was in a back and forth at length
with some twitter folks you know
folks who work at the company whose job
it was they saw hey you know what let's
reach out to conservatives who are
you know who have a uh a platform on
online
and uh and i went at them and i said
look
your um your shadow banning you're doing
all of these things you're throttling
the amount of views that people will get
that that
viewers will get and they denied all of
this
but they admitted to having i think some
300 different
metrics or types of metrics
that will decide who you are based on
behaviors
right so that they can look you in the
eye and they say we do not
ban conservatives there is it is the
stupidest lie
and the issue i guess is i don't i don't
know
why any conservative would believe them
and i don't know why any conservatives
argue them
i've argued with them but we know
they're lying they know we know they're
lying
and they know we know they know they're
lying they they know we know
they know we know they're lying yes yeah
i wrote a piece about it at uh
at uh the federalist i think in 20
2018 describing this whole back and
forth
and uh and i told them you know my
twitter hasn't grown
more than i don't know 200 300 in the
last
nine months it's obvious that something
is going on because
because of how you know exponential
growth works right and the guy looked at
me and said
maybe your tweets just aren't so good we
can offer you
a class on how to tweet better wow yeah
i mean the chutzpah
yeah you know and and this guy had like
you know 400 followers or something and
he had his and he's
and he's talking to me and and it's like
i mean it's so obvious that the finger
is on the scale it's so obvious that
that this is going on it's not even
debatable but of course
you've got you know we went through four
years
of donald trump yeah where i knew this
was a problem in in january of 2017. you
know i mean i
i'm not special a lot of people saw that
this was an issue
and nothing was done the republicans
didn't do anything about it when they
didn't
do it nothing and they're not gonna know
we get hearing after hearing after
hearing they don't do anything oh at the
uh at the federal level absolutely not
federal level all these guys so desantis
so i was there
at the uh at the bill signing i was
there at the bill signing
and uh and it was great the room was
electric
because everybody knows what
is is up here everybody knows it used to
be that it's like okay
you know milo alex jones these people
who
you know you'd never meet in a million
years but you know
they got banned but now it's grandma
getting banned
yeah it's people who are just saying you
know learn to code making jokes
right now here's where it gets crazy you
ready for this one tech groups
sue desantis i know over social media
bill
knew it i thought this i thought it was
gonna i thought someone in florida was
gonna file a lawsuit against the big
tech companies immediately instead
so the way around you get you get a few
minutes a few days and whoever strikes
first it's basically when if you're
gonna two countries are gonna go to war
one of them gets to declare the war and
invade and if you wait the other one's
gonna invade you so you invade first
let's let's see what we got here they
say two technology groups on thursday
filed a lawsuit in tallahassee federal
court
challenging a controversial bill that
governor desantis said is aimed at
cracking down on social media censorship
but opponents argue it's an
unconstitutional infringement of free
speech
that's factually not true it's not well
it's the free speech of the corporation
right but uh the the issue is so we've
had an interesting conversation about
this
uh the new york times for instance
if they take an article from you and
publish it it's their speech
what happens if you write the article
submit it through a
submissions portal and then they publish
it that's actually your speech even
though they chose to publish through a
submission portal does that make sense
no and that's the way it works right now
so no this does not actually stop the
corporation's free speech
no of course i mean i agree with you but
that's our that's argument that they're
making
there's it's it's a fake argument it's a
fake argument but all of this is good
you know right it's got to go through
the courts it's got to be fought
you know frankly the thing that needs to
happen right now is
you know you've got to get some
conservative donors
putting some money into into fighting
this in a
in a in a public in a public way let's
get some c4s let's get
people out there pushing this everybody
knows i think this is
a huge issue 501c3 could handle sure
political sure
just going after censorship in general
is a tax deductible cause
uh yeah and and and supporting someone
and supporting some of this pushback you
know even if
desantis will because it's you know as
you know it's not just one
thing on one issue you know he's doing
the the you know the
riot stuff he's doing other stuff
you know they're going to take him to
court for for over everything yup
and it seems i mean sadly i look i loved
ron desantis i think florida is the best
state in the union right now
but unfortunately we're alone
and this has got to change i love it
here let me read this quote
americans everywhere should oppose
florida's attempt to run roughshod over
the first amendment rights of private
online businesses
says carl zabo vice president and
general counsel of net choice
by weakening the first amendment rights
of some florida weakens the first
amendment rights of all uh-huh let me
just explain something the bill targets
i think if they have to have like 100
million users yeah
oh oh since when have has the left been
like
but what about the ultra wealthy and the
massive multinational corporations
who's going to protect them that's where
they're at right now
this is the funniest thing i saw
somebody uh they were commenting about
uh ted cruz he made a comment about
your medical choices should be your
choice and no government should
intervene
and all these leftists are like
high-fiving like oh yeah now do abortion
and i'm like that's really funny because
you can make fun of ted cruz but what
about the defected liberals who have
always been in favor of regulating
massive corporations or who have been
pro-choice the whole time and are
telling you you're insane
see they ignore people like me because
it's inconvenient it's convenient for me
to a certain degree because then i don't
get the smear pieces coming out all the
time
but yeah when i say 10 years ago we got
to regulate these massive corporations
that are that are that are stealing the
commons
and polluting our waters and colluding
with foreign interests
and then they say the same thing now i'm
still saying the same thing oh but it
benefits conservatives
so now they're not going to say anything
and then what they'll do is when a
conservative comes out they say
you just hate free speech you're you
you're going to regulate these companies
take away their free speech rights
because corporations are people my
friend the hotspot of these people is
is so far beyond it's so far beyond
anything
because i mean in in my mind there's
there it's very simple
is there such a thing as a public square
is it possible for a public square to be
owned
in 2021 by a private entity
yes of course yep yes of course this is
obvious
you know this is what a lot of the
libertarian types and the people you
know frankly who are taking a ton of
money from
you know from big tech are saying is
that they're denying that this is a
thing
um and the other thing is if you
you know you are allowing these
corporations to have more power than
governments yeah india well the people's
government hungary
poland the us all these other places
have gotten into conflicts with these
big tech
companies the big tech companies usually
end up winning
and this is and it's and it's and it's
uh it's crazy because they are
unaccountable to anybody i mean is this
a
and it really speaks to what this
government is
my favorite group of people in all of
this are the libertarians
who you know should be on the side of
the free speech of the individual but
instead are on the on the side of
free speech for the massive
multinational corporations and the
alarks algox behind them
the reason i love it is because they
hate they hate them
mark zuckerberg facebook they hate
libertarians they despise them
they ban them and shut them down and so
you have like
there's three groups right now you've
got the the democrat
large left umbrella which includes some
leftists
who uh as glenn greenwald i think was
glenn greenwald who said this they're
the one group of people with the least
ability to learn
because they advocate for censorship and
then they keep getting censored
you have conservatives who are like well
we normally don't
we aren't for regulation but in this
instance we recognize the importance of
it and we must have our rights protected
and i'm like make sense to me
and then you have libertarians who are
like we are being banned and
smeared and insulted i hope facebook has
the right to remove us
because in 20 years our ideology won't
exist anymore that's
it it's the most amazing thing the
libertarians i don't know i had a long
argument a couple years ago with this
libertarian guy
and he's like we shouldn't be telling
what these private businesses can or
can't do and i was like bro fine i don't
care
i was like i'm not i'm not i'm not lib
right i'm not in your bubble
so when you when facebook decides to
delete every single libertarian
candidate
and every single libertarian personality
which they're going to do and they do
anti-war.conference we had scott horton
in here he got uh anti-war.com got
censored why it's anti-establishment
they want war they want bombs so they
get banned too
and then they advocate for their own
banning it's remarkable like well they
shouldn't ban us i guess but it is a
private company
all right well in five years you won't
be a part of the conversation and i
won't have to argue with any with you
anymore so
whatever right there should also be a
distinction i mean i'm i'm not
actually for making this distinction
because i think that both of these
things
both you know the social media companies
and google
this you know and and other search
engine companies uh i mean we we have
the same problem with both of them
right but the libertarians
and the phony conservatives will um
you know i mean they they will they will
say that uh
that uh you know facebook and these
social media companies
um you know that you have alternatives
you don't have to exist on them
right but as far as the search engine
goes i mean google and
google is really the the institutional
memory
of western civilization at this point
and you you you just you take
something out of the search engine and
it's gone i often see stories pop up
from the gateway pundit
yeah and i don't like i don't not a big
fan of using them for the most part you
know they have some
credibility for some writers but i'll
see a story and i'll be like okay i
wanna i wanna fact check this and i'll
go on google and i'll type it in it's
like doesn't
doesn't exist there's a bunch of sites
that are just non-existent on google
andrew yang put it really well when he
was talking about anti-trust not being
the right answer there needs to be
something else when he said how many of
you wanna use bing
and everyone like laughs he's like
exactly nobody's gonna use bing
it's like google is the service google's
what people use but duckduckgo is
is is moving in and it's it's it's an
opportunity to use something the problem
is
we're trying to market right that's the
thing i
i invent look at this i got a bottle of
water and i want to get this bottle of
water to as many people as possible
so you go where the people are uh
facebook
and google have bought up the largest
spaces and they're now privately owned
public spaces
do you know what you know what a pops is
in new york or privately owned public
space
no so this is what happened with occupy
wall street
zuccotti the where they had the protest
was privately owned
but because it was open to the public
they couldn't evict the protesters
they were allowed to protest there so i
tried explaining this people i'm like
okay check it out so so the
the ultra rich people like deutsche bank
or whatever they have these privately
owned public spaces
and the courts ruled that you can
privately own them
but as long as you welcome the public in
you can't shut down
first amendment activity so occupy wall
street was allowed to stay so long as
they like
what's the benefit of owning them then
so they buy property for the property
value
but then what do you do with it they
turn it into a public space
and just let it be a park or something
there's probably some right off there
somewhere some city benefits i'm sure
there's some right off there but
regardless i don't know exactly other
than if you're open to the public then
first amendment rights apply to you not
to
them right and so now you have twitter
it is a public space a public forum it's
already been ruled the public forum in
the past although that
did get overturned by the supreme court
people go there to speak
a private corporation owns it they
should not have the right to shut down
the speech of an individual
if we're to operate on the assumption
that this is a violation
of twitter's free speech rights
then you're suggesting that twitter is
speaking for us
like when i tweet with my face next to
my words you're saying
twitter is being compelled to speak no
it isn't it's a utility
it's it's a platform everyone knows
twitter didn't say that
so what's the excuse that's it it's just
a lie
because they know right now the
democrats are like look these people who
run these companies are
are on our side so we'll just agree with
them conservatives
they're getting wiped out and i i think
that was a huge contributing factor to
trump losing in
2020 i'm finding it's a very different
situation to walk into twitter's
one of their buildings and start saying
what you think and then getting
arrested or taken out by their public
private security that's
probably building yeah it's private
building but when you use a service
online
it's not a private building anymore so
their right to censor you and stop you
seems to end at the door of their
headquarters or of their of their own
property so i that's kind of the way i'm
looking at it
you know if you set up your your
business in walmart
walmart can shut you down at will but if
you have a business on youtube you're
not
in youtube's building anymore you're not
right on that problem
the big problem i think is
for one people need to sue more
conservatives should have been suing and
you know what really annoys me is i hear
from all these conservative lawyers
you can't because you're going to lose
because of this precedent i don't care
just sue just sue just
james o'keefe look at that guy yes he's
like
fires him missiles you know he just goes
for it
and then he actually ends up winning
defeating emotion to dismiss in the new
york times case
everyone said it can't be done until he
did it
too many too many people aren't pushing
back
they're getting censored they don't sue
a lot of people sue and they lose but
good for them for at least trying
set precedent get better arguments
i mean all of this too is like um
you know they're they're trying to
they're trying whatever arguments that
they can come up with
because what they really want to do is
they really want to control the flow of
information
and they are un their world view has
been
rocked to its core by trump's victory
yeah and by the fact that there is stuff
out there online that they
don't like they thought they would be
ushering in a new era
of online um you know woke you know new
consciousness where everything
they didn't see that that you know there
would be an underbelly
i mean the underbelly is us you know you
know what i think they didn't see it
i grew up online i've had the internet
as long as i can remember my family at
comp you serve on dos or whatever
yes then we had compuserve on windows
and then we had aol
so i've been in the chat rooms and i
have been exposed to the nastiness that
is the internet my whole life and i knew
the trolls and the hackers and the memes
so growing up i'm like welcome to the
internet but a lot of these people
they probably did not have the internet
at a young age that i
a lot of people i went to school with
didn't have computers so it was a time
when
i'm a little kid i have a windows 3.1
machine not everybody had a computer in
their house
they weren't using aol not only that if
the parents were they're not letting
their kids go in a chat room
and here then you see nasty adult stuff
so what happens is these millennials
they grow up and it's not until their
teens they actually get on the internet
and they're in more safe environments
with more restrictions now they're
adults
and they're oh no people are saying mean
things online how can this be and
interestingly
you know mark zuckerberg and jack dorsey
have decided to decide with that faction
why
it's really simple take conservative
take a liberal
put him in a room and then yell a a
curse word guess who's gonna care
guess who's gonna scream yeah and so if
you're running a business
and you're selling donuts and then you
have a conservative and a liberal there
and one of your employees stubs his toe
and screams ah
f guess which one's gonna complain so
are they going to do in any way anyway
pander to the ideology of the
conservative who didn't care someone
blurted out a cuss word
or are they going to go to the karen and
be like but that's 1.0
i think what you're describing is kind
of 1.0 at 2.0 where we're at or whatever
whatever number we're at
um you've got 80 percent
of the company let's say from middle
management on down
that is totally woke that is going to
revolt if you don't do anything exactly
so you know so if you're running the
company i mean i i know people who
or heard of people who um
you know feel like they're not in
control of their own company
that's kind of sad it is kind of sad
it's you know once you let it grow to be
too big and you know what
this don't hire woke don't hire well
don't hire woke
if you're hiring woke then you don't
know the game never get invested don't
take investments if you don't need them
right don't take investments man
so you look at like the intercept with
glenn greenwald yeah well go broke yeah
glenn greenwald had to resign from his
own company he had no control over it
he created a monster and now it's just
rampaging around
it's a bummer i mean good for him for
speaking out against it but
he made him he made this machine of
course
he has no control over no and and they
won i mean he's
he's doing great work outside of you
know outside of that
that uh and they've got his funding that
organization but but yeah right
i mean how many years did he spend how
many years did he spend putting his
credibility on the line
asking for the money the interceptor
right now is a skin suit
with some kind of skin walker inside of
it and it's like you know
it's like a yeah you know that you know
yeah when the bug alien is in the edgar
suit rock
social justice that's that's what it is
the new york times the same way just
keeps happening and uh yeah
and look i mean they're they're like you
know digital hessians for antifa too
because they'll go and they'll you know
they'll serve the purpose of marking the
target
well what a pessimistic friday night
oh we can we can we can keep going
[Laughter]
yes we mentioned earlier that we were
talking about that gain of function this
is a little going back to where we're
talking about earlier
that you'd said in that story that the
u.s made it illegal to do gain of
function research
it was temporarily outlawed oh so it's
legal again no i think they shut it down
recently
and but so then they were paying a
company to fund it in china instead
no the money was a grant was given to
ecohealth and then ecohealth
gave the money to one so it's like that
we didn't not our business
where else are they doing gain of
function research that we're paying for
everywhere but we're not paying for
we're paying someone else to pay for it
for us with our money
right as if you know as if uh
you know the other countries in the
world can't also pay for this yeah i
mean imagine how much of this stuff is
going on
at all times right now in any number of
labs around the world
probably a lot it's probably creepy okay
i'm sure it's a lot worse than we
realized though you know
you have this this one lab in wuhan
where they're doing this research
imagine what the us government has under
under lock
area yeah if they're going to be if
they're going to be finding funding to
different labs in other countries
imagine what they do when they actually
have their hands on the project you know
what i mean
when i heard about the story immediately
i thought maybe this is like a cia black
site
type of thing yeah where they say you
know what the really sketchy stuff we're
going to put it abroad
yeah we'll pay we'll underwrite it that
makes sense we'll put it abroad the
really sketchy stuff
but it's exactly the opposite you know
when you're dealing with sensitive
things like this it's not like you know
it's not like a cia black site in egypt
where you know a jihadi guy is getting
his
you know his mouth chopped off
something's happening sure yeah
something's happening but like there's
limited fallout from that
compared to a wuhan virus
play uh play dangerous games man with
dangerous prizes
yeah yeah yeah hey david can we talk
about your book for a minute sure
a minute i'll hold it up yeah this is so
this is about qatar you said there was a
shadow what's it called exactly
it's qatar qatar's shadow war the
islamist emirate
and its information operations in the
united states so the first thing i
thought was this is an american shadow
war in qatar
you were saying there's actually how do
you say qataris what's the
what's the word qatari this is a qatari
shadow war
basically being waged upon the united
states
for their let's say in the um
media and government of the united
states
for uh you know for qatar's advantage
and for the advantage of
islamism um it's um i mean
real you know kind of really short story
is qatar is the state sponsor of the
muslim brotherhood
oh wow and they run al jazeera plus they
run to zero plus
ultra woke network with billions of
views on facebook
and they run a lot of other stuff too i
mean they run you know
brookings oldest and biggest think tank
in the world oh yeah
they're ron brookings i mean to the
extent that run
it's very creatively you know described
so they will go there will be big donors
into brookings the u.s
but then they have a franchise so they
have
they have brookings doha which is
uh you know owned by the royal family of
qatar that's in qatar
and you know that's a black box of
funding i mean they don't have to tell
us what
you know how much money comes in there
so they use that um
that brand as as legitimacy
so what are they what are they doing
what are they doing to us so i mean
basically they're um they're doing a
couple things
i argue that the arab spring
that happened in let's say late 2010 up
until 2011
was a project of the qataris through al
jazeera and the brotherhood to
destabilize the middle east
really al jazeera was
let's say the primary mover of a lot of
those protests
and not only that it was you know
between al jazeera and
brookings and all the other assets that
qatar had in the united states
it was able to convince journalists and
politicians
um and influencers of of other types
that you know these um
these governments in the middle east
that you know have supported us and
we've supported for all these years
uh we should not support you know
mubarak we should support you know the
revolution
against against him let's say in egypt
um and the same thing in libya the libya
war was a total
al jazeera qatari production i mean
hillary clinton really wanted that
yes what did she say though we came we
saw he died no
she said look at this she was in the
front of the senate and she went
on and on about how wonderful al jazeera
coverage is she said there's
her quote was that is real news but was
it because they were
they were supporting what she wanted um
yes so there was there was there was an
alignment there
what i believe she wanted there was
and what the whole obama crowd wanted
with libya was
they wanted to go in they wanted an
opportunity they saw what was
on al jazeera they saw the whole arab
world lining up against gaddafi
and they thought okay bush is gone
we want to start a new leaf we've made
the cairo speech we want to be good to
muslims
we want to do something to make the
muslim world like us
all they care about is getting rid of
gaddafi we're going to get rid of
gaddafi
and you know and um and we're going to
show them to stabilize the entire
northern african region destabilized
everything right yeah
so so um so
all of the information for this came
from
al jazeera it came from sort of you know
qatari influence operators
but i wonder if they were just doing
what we want they're just doing what
what
hillary clinton and and obama what they
wanted in
north africa i mean especially when you
look at syria with the cutter turkey
pipeline
sure it would have been very beneficial
to cutter
but uh the us wanted to run a pipeline
up through syria and turkey into the
into
you know europe to offset the monopoly
coming from gazprom through ukraine
and uh cutter was like we'll make money
doing it i guess so let's just
say what they want say what america
wants america gives us stuff
we're going to make money in the deal so
report what's good for them
yeah i i think it's um i think they're
dumber than that
all right i honestly mean they seem to
be successful yeah i legit
think that they're that they're more
ideological than that
um i mean it's a mix right it's it's a
mix i mean there's there's plenty of
i mean the libya thing is is a great
example because you've got sydney
blumenthal
you know ready to make millions in there
there are a lot of shady shady stuff um
as far as you know politicians or people
connected to politicians involved in
that
who are standing to make money off let's
say post war
libya um but still regardless
there's a story that needs to be told in
public
for for anything to happen you know
you're talking about the syria thing
right people need a public narrative
people needed a public narrative
for libya too regular americans man uh
it's just
it's it's it's maddening
when i try and have send out
conversations and they just don't know
don't care
and i'm like you're giving your money
and your vote to people
who hate you and are destroying the
planet
and they're like now do you think they
always didn't care
yes that's that's that's effective
propagandizing you know and when you
look at these schools how they're doing
critical race theory
which is making a lot of these kids just
i mean what was that report that came
out like the u.s is failing
fourth graders are proficiency in signs
like 20 or some ridiculously low number
because they don't they don't know
anything critical race theory
deconstruct deconstructivism whatever
you want to call it what they're doing
deconstruction
these kids are going to be dumb as a box
of rocks when they're older sure and
you're going to have a very very loyal
base of dumb
people voting for whatever you tell them
to vote for
what's the point of running a country
what's the point of anything they're
doing
that's why i say they're extracting
value from the system and watching it
burn to the ground
because if your kids are going to be
dumb when you die
you'll have dumb people running the
country ugh worse than the dumb people
running
it now so i think we're screwed with
that they go for the kids
they teach them things like two plus two
equals five you saw this stuff right on
twitter
why would you teach a kid two plus two
equals five so they're too stupid
to build to construct like a doorknob
oh i i got two pieces but how do i have
four doorknobs it's like right and on
one doorknob on the same token you've
got the the coddling of the american
mind was like
what what is it jonathan yeah yeah who
wrote that um
that this whole thing you know all of
wokeness could be
understood to be a you know like how do
you make someone crazy
how do you make someone crazy how do you
make someone anti-social how do you make
someone
unable to relate to you know
to others and that's what they're doing
yeah and then they're creating
a a pitchfork mob that's what it is on
twitter there's
people marching around torches and
pitchforks looking for something because
they're angry
no rhyme or reason talk about wearing
masks and being afraid of each that
someone else is infected with a virus
making people anti-social especially
like young kids
that can't see faces you can't you're
forced to cover yourself
i mean but in specifically in reference
to educating kids and educating them in
ways that make no sense
it's a wonderful incident is the big one
telling people the al altering the
history of the united states
now what you're going to have is you're
going to have some kids growing up
learning about ridiculous fake history
and other kids learning different
history and what's the what's the result
civil war yeah
people we have we have other options
peace i mean
civil war is i mean we even have things
that we need to do before peaceful
divorce which is
which is a piece that i wrote that i'm
still preparing it's a longer thing
called autonomy
which talks about the need for
let's say red america to create the
things that
frankly we don't have like uh
like financial institutions like social
media networks
no i like you know this this is this is
a problem the problem is that the the
the the cult infiltrated and took them
over and then conservatives are like
well i'll go make my own it's like what
you had one
they took it from you well they may have
taken some businesses but like they
didn't when people say let's take back
the culture
we never had the culture the culture was
always in the hands of
the federal reserve you know
organizations the hands of the left
not the federal government right that's
the left but
uh but no i mean i think we need
autonomy we need to be making our own
things and i mean
doing what you're doing that's true and
uh here's what i think's going to happen
in 20 years you're going to have a large
amount half
population are going to believe the
united states was founded in 1619 as a
slaveocracy
sure and then you're going to have
another half that thinks the country was
founded in 1776
as a classical liberal revolution of the
mind uh
you know from the colonists if you can't
agree on what your country is
then you can't function and we're
already the point where
you know i look at chuck schumer in the
in the january 6th commission
these people are evil evil people
it's funny because you can look at
objective reality look at all of the
videos i watched
as many videos from january 6 as as much
as i could
and i can tell you that there were some
people who were very violent it was a
riot there were some people that were
let in by the police and the police
agreed to work with them
the police opened the door for many of
these people so how do i know it's more
likely to be true that's the case
i watched all of the videos and i've had
the reporters who were there on the
ground interviewed on this
show and what the democrats are saying
is
psycho is psychotic it is deception
it is lies and the democratic voters buy
it all up
without ever having looked at any of the
evidence without ever having watched
anything they are mindless drones and
they are advocating for
fascism and i mean it i mean they've
already put these things in place
i mean they've they've um they've
already retooled there's a great
thread that i'll i'll find i'll i'll
sort of retweet it
about all the things that the um that
the let's say the
national security state homeland
security state has done
to to address the the january 6th issue
and it's a revolution i mean they're
retooling everything from they're flying
black lives matter flags
at our embassies yeah that's it the
there is
a cold civil war it's been going on for
years i did not coin the phrase it was a
princeton professor who did he's a
democrat
and uh they they they won now now it's
the resistance
most of the prominent uh uh we'll call
them belligerence in the traditional war
sense
have been purged from the culture war
sure alex jones milo
john f kennedy martin luther king i mean
this has been going on for a long time
dude this cold civil war this game
actually was co-opted in 1946 talking
specifically about what's going on right
now you're talking about
modern day a bunch of people have been
banned and removed from the fight
outright
what's left are moderate types that are
like i reject
and that's it and
we watch as the embassies fly the flag
of a cult ideology
all right so so use the master you see
it i see it
what fascinates me now is are the people
who refuse to see it
and um i i just wrote a piece at the
american mind which is a
fantastic website about um
about sort of uh disengaging with these
people on politics
it's like if you have a fundamental
disagreement about
where you see these things going like if
you think that oh
you know we'll be able to snap back into
1980 or 19 or
or you know 2004 then you know what
maybe we don't talk about politics we'll
talk about music we're just not going to
go there
because this to me seems like like such
a no-brainer
i mean you had today i saw a guy who was
a kind of more um
nice guy but a kind of more
establishment conservative
writer he says you know what we can't
between crt on one hand
and let's say the the conservative
vision of education
of the founding on the other we have no
disagreement we have no
no agreement so we can't really have
public education anymore because it
doesn't have a unifying
you know ethos okay you got it
apply that to the rest of the country so
if
conservatives aren't actively trying to
educate people as to what's going on
then the left just wins it's over
and it's already hard enough with the
cultural institutions controlled by the
left and the constant stream of lies
the big lie from democrats about january
6 is just one
big lie they don't want you to know that
the police opened the door they don't
they don't want you to know that the
doors were opened by the cops and they
don't want you to watch the video where
that cue shaman
walks up to a cop and the cop says we're
going to work with you bp's one of those
you got it buddy right
and they don't tell you they don't want
you to know that a story came out about
the cue shaman stopping other people
from stealing from the break room
that he was saying we were going to have
a peaceful protest no they want him to
rot in solitary confinement
then you watch as police over the past
year
this is the problem with conservatives
police over the past year have been
arresting people
for minor violations on like wearing
masks there's no
law there was never a law when they said
when they shut these people's business
down
it was an edict a governor said i say it
and it is so and the cop went you got it
and then started beating and arresting
random people
and the conservatives went back to blue
baby now once it started getting extreme
conservatives actually started backing
away from the police and pushing back
against them
but it's starting to come back to the
i'm seeing more and more conservatives
defending the cops again
and i'm like bro there's a lady in
florida i think no no i'm sorry
elizabeth city north carolina
she was driving one mile an hour through
a crowd of black lives matter people who
were banging on her car
and they're charging her with two felony
counts the police did that
okay your institutions are controlled by
the cult the cops that are there right
now are the mindless drones
who would beat their own mother if their
boss told them to do it
you've got black lives matter flags
flying at the embassies you've got the
fbi
posting photos of people saying we're
going to get each and every one of these
guys
nothing happens to black lives matter
some things do do you know
you know you know how you there's
there's a really interesting pattern
that emerges
the people who were protesting for black
lives matter and rioting the ones who
the ones who were riding and they got
arrested do you know why those
particular individuals got arrested
it's usually like they threw a brick at
a police department
they attacked a government building
specifically but when it comes to the
burning down of businesses
those people are free to go the the guy
who died in the pawnshop that burned
down to minneapolis
now we're not going to worry about that
at all oh but what was that that bubba
dude from nascar
the garage pole rub looked like a noose
better sending a dozen agents so this is
definitional anarcho-tyranny
yes exactly it is what it is you know
these uh well maybe but no i think we've
just
i think that the cult is in control and
i think
conservatives sure i mean you can still
fight well right so you can say that you
know in in
in in many ways blm antifa
or agents of the state they are
absolutely agents of the state you know
and you know and uh
and and if you you know you fall outside
that you know you're on the right you're
uh you know that's exactly how it works
then i can i can sit here
and the hammer comes down but but a
mythology has to be created in order for
this thing to hold a mythology has to be
created about
our unique particular evil
which is what january 6th is right which
is the you know and
the commission is is this is the idea
what we're going to do now is we're
going to spend the next
x number of months to keep hammering
home every day
that um you know why these guys are
uniquely evil why this is the enemy that
you need to hate if you are a good
american
yep and republicans sided with democrats
on this one in the house and in the
senate
yeah look i mean it's shameful it's
shameful that
that i mean forget about trump right
this is not even about trump it's about
it's about sort of like baseline um
political warfare baseline awareness of
where we are in the movie you know this
is this is clearly what they're trying
to do
they're trying to to uh to create and to
um
you know they're trying to to create
this this uh this phantom enemy
if if if this is a trilogy we just
wrapped up the
the middle second movie where it ends
with a cliffhanger where the heroes lose
no the two towers ended with them
smashing up eisenguard that was awesome
tree beard he's like we're going to war
and i'm like yeah
no it's more like uh maybe star wars
where
you know an empire it's like khan's
frozen and like the empire's back and
they're like oh no and it's like stay
tuned to the next movie
so it's like you get the start of the
culture war and it ends with the great
victory of donald trump and everyone's
like yeah
then you get part two and it's donald
trump's presidency but then oh no
the empire strikes back and now we're
sitting there with the
mega death star with the force field on
it and uh we'll see we'll see how it
goes maybe someone will pick up the
emperor and throw him down a shaft
or or maybe we're really early in the
movie
so that's what that's what i was
thinking you know really or even in the
or even in the prequels
uh the prequels yeah i mean who knows i
mean it's that bad right
uh and uh i don't know like you know in
the star wars prequels
they were there there were there was
turmoil but it was still like the
republic existed
yeah let me yeah maybe maybe let me ask
you i know we're i was just talking
earlier about
strauss and how in the fourth turning
yes do you know
john zanakis and um and generational
dynamics
no don't explain it you need to get into
this guy
uh when i was uh helping andrew
breitbart put together
uh a big piece he was the first guy that
i reached out to
john zinakis who has uh a website called
generational dynamics
basically the strauss and howe thesis is
that
you know america has four you know four
turns four terms
and seasons keeps going different
seasons of generations
so just we'll give the for people who
aren't familiar the real quick is
you get a period of of what is it uh of
after a crisis
there's like a great growth then there's
a period of sort of like
the high we level off then things start
to shake then you get a crisis
then it goes after the crisis things get
better again right so there's four
stages
and if you go back from now like 80
years you had world war ii before the
civil war before that you had the
revolutionary cycle of approximately 80
years so we are in the fourth turning
right now
right so anyway continue anyway yeah
yeah so i mean
real quick sorry which means we should
be expecting a very serious crisis
on the scale of war within the next
seven years right generational crisis
period right
so i mean it's not it's not new it's
he's taking the cycle of regimes
and he's compressing it and you know and
looking at a different way anyway what
zanakis was doing was he's applying this
to international affairs
so if you're looking at like america is
following along one particular
rotation let's say you've got let's say
you're talking about america
and england england has its own rotation
right iraq has its own rotation so it
enables you
to um to predict what is going to happen
and war and and in these things well no
i mean
it's it's a methodology more than a um
uh you know more than a particular
i think i think there's going to be a
collapse um if you look at
this this drastic generational theory
whether it's true or not i mean maybe
it's just a coincidence that we've had
these periods
and and often you know uh people point
out like what about
korean war about vietnam what about you
know iraq afghanistan where do these fit
into these theories and things like that
so so so maybe it'll happen maybe it
won't but i do see
when you have the democrats lying and
it is relentless it is a zombie horde
they never stop there's no break there's
no calm there's no peace there's no
compromise
and the best part is they wield the
propaganda machines and the big tech
establishment
to claim it's the republicans who are
doing that when the republicans are
sleeping on the job
so what happens is i sit here every day
at best they're sleeping in the job yeah
some of them are just absent
so i sit here every day watching the
news and i'm like here we go again the
democrats are lying about
everything and the republicans have some
of them are agreeing with the democrats
and the rest of them are just sitting
there acting like speed bumps
so you watch them you watch the empire
taking control
and i really want to stress a point i've
been making all week when people would
say how did nazi germany get so bad
where everybody's doing the roman salute
people in this country for the past year
have been doing the red salute
on marches in the thousands defying the
edicts
of the governors in which conservatives
got arrested because they were defying
the mandates
yet these red saluting extremists
and regular people who joined in get a
pass they didn't wear masks
they didn't lock down and nothing was
done about it and when you look at new
york what did what did de blasio
say well they're allowed to do that but
what happened when the conservatives
stood on the steps of the michigan state
house waving a little gadsden flag oh
terrorist attack yeah well i got to be
careful because the people doing the red
salute could be
if you look at world war ii metaphor the
communists
that they developed the nazi party to
counter so we got to be careful that we
don't end up creating a movement to
counter
this woke mob that ends up becoming the
dangers i don't think there's anything
you can do about it no
what do you mean of course we can no
we're creating it as we go
no see what happens is there's a for
every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction
when you get thousands of people
marching through the streets doing the
red salute
don't be surprised when you get a
counter force it is you can't
you have you'll have an energetically
equal response but the way it
manifests is up to us it could be
violent it could be peaceful
it could be organized it could be
chaotic it's going to be the exact same
thing
i don't think so it it shows itself in
different ways it might be another party
like you saw the proud boys
kind of but that that floundered more or
less i don't know they got crushed by
the state yeah
and antifa is protected by anything
anything that comes up by the
from the right that looks anything like
antifa is going to be crushed yeah they
don't want another
that's what that's exactly what january
that's what it's about it's in order to
stop that and frankly it's in order to
to
to stop any more rallies right
and people are afraid to have rallies
you have a rally and they're going to
make the claim january 6 january 6
oh no yup correct and and they have
i mean part of you know in my in my kind
of past life i was doing
uh terrorism analysis and um you know so
i'm kind of intimately familiar with
what they're about to do to us here
which is um you know they've already
they've already created these absurd
metrics they've already created
um you know ideological screens and
tests for
who is a terrorist and all of us here
frankly you know fall under it oh yeah
and
um you know and and and this is how they
will justify i mean
you know this is how they will justify
using social media companies
right to go after us you know financial
institutions things like that
so it's it's better it's very bad you
look you look back at history and you
can see the assassination plots
against uh certain you know to according
to the government the undesirable
uh figures the activists who are leading
the charges for social change and stuff
so they should have killed people
but at certain point they realize you
create martyrs you make people immortal
then we see julian assange what do they
do to him characters keep him in a box
character assassination destroy his
legacy now
the left that used to love the man hate
the man they despise him he's a he's a
rapist
it's not true that's read the news it's
all clearly fake and made up
and then lock him in a box and let him
slowly die a slow and miserable death
julian assange did a bunch of really
great work exposing a lot of the
corruption
and so they figured out the best way to
deal with them is to make sure he'll
never be a martyr
don't let him die let him slowly rot
away and lose his mental faculties
and then accuse him of extremely heinous
crimes so that people are scared to say
they support them
that's what's in store for everybody
else but it also means that
there's not going to be trains they're
not going to round people up
that's not going to happen what's going
to happen is they're going to shut off
your credit card
and then you're going to starve and then
they're going to say well but it's a
private company
oh but you know go use your us dollars
go buy oh but the store doesn't take
cash well that's too bad you should
maybe you shouldn't be a bigot bigot
my friend just lost her paypal why she
has no idea
gone yep you know she's public and on
the right
it could be anything yeah and uh you
know
take away your access to banking which
they've done to the proud boys they've
done to a bunch of groups
it's amazing it's happening and it's
getting worse every day what did they
say yesterday gradually and then
suddenly someone said in the super chats
yeah
and it's and it's remarkable it comes
from
hemingway yeah it's how do you go broke
yep
gradually and then suddenly from a
moveable feast so what we have now is uh
i think i i don't think it's uh uh
the night is always darkest before the
dawn but i don't think it's completely
hopeless i think what will happen is
there will be a collapse i think the
states will split apart i think florida
ron desantis
is fl i know people who
if i if i have a friend who's moving you
know they're moving to texas or florida
sure
yep and i'm like come on west virginia
what are you doing
look honey how do you compete with i i i
can though you know
how do you compete with uh with the with
the beach it's very hard
yeah but the weather it's so humid it's
so hot it's very hard
it's like 10 000 degrees literally like
i swear i saw someone just like burst
into flames on tina's looking bust once
when i was in miami and i'm like ah
like i had to run run to shade as like
have you seen um
the have you seen the core where they go
to the center of the earth to reset the
core
there's a scene where like oh so it's a
documentary yeah
there's a scene where like because the
magnetosphere is weak solar microwaves
beam through and it's like this beam is
just
melting like the golden gate bridge and
it's collapsing because it's so hot
that's like miami it's like that yeah
like you're just walking on the beach
you see that everyone runs from the
from the sun and people are just being
melted and no it's not that bad but
they're going to florida and texas
because of the laws
because florida and texas are actually
protecting individual rights
and resisting all this stuff you look at
these blue states
that's bad and what's really bad is the
stuff we're talking about with the cult
it's blue states putting in people to
federal level who then exert authority
over red states
makes no sense or like somebody in west
virginia wants to go hunt
feral hogs with their with their buddy
down the street and they lend him a gun
it's fine not in the blue states i don't
i think that we've been negligent
about a lot of thing but about a lot of
local politics
in in this country um we have this
every four years we have this big
nonsense going on in washington dc about
who gets to be the president
we've got big nonsense every two years
about congress et cetera et cetera
nobody knows who their senator or you
know people know maybe who their senator
is nobody knows who their representative
is
nobody knows who the mayor is et cetera
et cetera we need we in red states need
to look around
and get into this yes local yes all the
way
people ask me oh you know do you think
so and so will be you know
we'll run for the house who cares i
don't care you know what really bothered
me
a lot of republicans did this too they
were like my you know
our district is bad and if you vote for
me i'll fix the district and i'm like no
you won't because you're a federal
politician
the person who's going to fix the
district is the alderman it's or the or
the local state senator or state rep
the the person running for congress is
going to go to the federal government to
represent your district to the federal
government
they're going to be voting on war not
voting on whether or not to claim the
trash in your neighborhood
but they all run on this yep what do
they say like i'll get money federal
money for it
that's vague it's like if you look at
our district you can see how bad things
have gotten with crime on the rise and
i'm like i don't care you don't
represent those problems
the local politicians do you're going to
go to dc
and they're going to ask you should we
bomb this country and you're
representing this district as to whether
or not we bomb the country and they're
going to vote yes i think the nice thing
about the internet
is that you can do the local politics
and show the world how it's done
with internet video and then they can
emulate it so you kind of create a
decentralized organiza
organizational you know pattern where
where we can make a really cool
youtube show about what it's like to run
local government
in the next city we'll be like i want to
do that too and then all over the world
at once
i've got a solution i've got a solution
to all of our political problems
i call it marsism yes and
we need elon musk to help create this
new form of government it's very simple
every time someone runs for office at
the federal level
and wins they go on to a ship which
sends them to mars
that's it that's it that's a long
commute to work
no no they just go to mars they just go
we just we just move the government
no the government the individuals who
win it's like yay get in the gym
what if it's better on bars that's great
good for them they'll have a good time
right
and then we won't have them to bug us i
guess that's true
i guess that's i guess that's true nancy
pelosi you've won for the 30th time
here's your rocket ship thank you elon
and then she gets in and it's like you
know we do i would we just did the
teachers unions first
oh yeah yeah we we put the that would be
fun the capitol building
i got an idea this january 6th thing
it's real bad all right these people
this insurrection
i know how to prevent it have the
capitol building be on mars
boom send all those people to mars and
they can
talk amongst themselves and vote how
they so choose and uh
they'll never have to worry about an
interaction ever again
reasonable i think you're so right about
that we need new industry
that we need new banking and new social
media um
like i think i see like a government
free software social media
service that's like based on the first
amendment the constitution
and like a banking system like on the
blockchain like do it a local level
florida should make it no joke
everybody has a role to play think about
think about this you know um
donald trump received how many votes in
2020 like 77
74.74 that's about the population of
france
it's more than france right so
so how many sure how many businesses
provide things for the french consumer
a lot this is a big market i mean it's
not a small number of people
texas florida here's what you do you
pass a bill right now that will create
a florida social network boom
look hungary just did this yeah they
just created their own social network
space that is familiar to facebook
hungrybooks
right um and uh you know but but
it's it's it's just trying to get off
the ground but you're gonna need this
type of thing
yep you're going to need this type of
people wouldn't use it right but but
here
i guess the problem is trump had the
opportunity to change the game and he
decided not to
exactly he did exactly trump needed to
do one thing
trump could have went on gab and said hi
yep
and that would have been a shock wave i
think about that with myself too i use
twitter
often and i'm like why don't i just post
on that it's not that it's that trump no
it's
commanded the news correct exactly and
so if trump said
if trump went on parlor gab or mines or
any platform and said
i am going to send a spaceship to the
moon
the media would be forced to report on
you know gab donald trump said this and
the reporters would be forced to sign up
to follow him
and trump would not do it and i guess it
was because jared kushner
who was just like don't do it donald
don't don't change
do don't take the power away from
silicon valley i'm not sure that that
was the case i mean the reporting was
that trump wanted to use parlor and
kushner said not to
so i don't know maybe it's not true i
don't i don't know i mean i would love
to know the
the ins and outs of that but but
absolutely it's absolutely inexcusable
what he did
and this is why i think i think desantis
should run in 2024 not trump
and i wonder where's trump jr to go go
to his dad and be like dad
get on gab like right now
isn't it too late oh it's way too late
it's way it's weird and not only that
instead of doing any of that he could he
could still do it it wouldn't matter as
much
he just makes his own website talk about
somebody cringe who just
exactly absolutely cringe so it's it's
unfortunate that was the best the
anti-establishment had
had to offer but look but this was this
was a problem throughout the trump years
which was that he consistently empowered
i mean look you're the president of the
united states you can say i'm going to
talk to whoever
you know whichever media outlet i want
and in so doing
you will elevate this outlet who did he
go to he talked
he talked to uh to new york times
washington
post yes you know yeah haberman he was
on the phone with her
all hours of the night you know it was
reported like you know
i'm sorry call the federalist call the
daily caller
you know yeah there's no there's no law
that says
the new york times and the washington
post need to have access it's because
republicans trump included care more
about what the new york times thinks
about them
than their own constituents maybe not so
much for trump but
for the republicans yes so the new york
times comes out and says you know this
politician
look at ted cruz right when he went on
vacation and then he flew back because
the media was yelling at him
that's so that's so lame what a loser do
you think he should have stopped
i like ted cruz so i'll take that one
back but uh it was pathetic
it was one of the most pathetic it's
like having a car you know i would beat
up
and crappy i would i would if i if i
went on vacation during a storm or
whatever
and the media got mad i'd get a cigar
what are those what are those things
called where you clip the cigar with it
you know what i mean clipper clipper i
don't know anything about the grass but
you know
i get one anyway i get like a velvet or
or a smoky jacket
no no no no like a robe a rope yeah okay
yeah yeah and then i
i turned a video on while i'm in
whatever place i put my feet up
i clipped the cigar i'd light it
and that's it well look that's how i've
added media that's how you have to do it
because you need to give them
at least at least as much contempt as
they give you
just stop bending the knee yeah well
the the the problem in american politics
i think the kind of crucial thing that
hit me one day i realized that a lot of
stuff makes sense
is that the democrat donor
is to the left of the democrat base yep
the republican donor is to the left of
the republican base
so what that does is that encourages the
left to move left
and encourages civil war on the right
did you see that video that's going
viral where the girl
shows the pregnancy test and then she's
crying like what am i you saw that
yeah i just thought today she's like
what am i gonna do huh just kidding she
throws it's like i already got the
appointment well and then she pours a
bottle of wine
i saw uh phil labonte tweeted it and he
was like
it's an abortion thing yeah an abortion
yeah yeah she was she's pro-choice
oh she already got that right she's
holding the pregnancy test going like oh
no what's going to happen and then
chuck's laughing ha ha
i am what conservatives fear and then
she drinks wine or something
and i'm like uh i'm not a conservative i
don't fear you but i am disgusted by you
because these leftists their their
ideology their mentality is built upon
one-upping each other on social media so
they don't realize that like i grew up
in a democrat household of pro-choice
individuals
who thought abortion was disgusting but
for political and liberty reasons and
medical reasons
we were pro-choice and it's a difficult
thing and i remember my dad would always
be like you know it's a really awful
thing
you should probably avoid it at all
costs but i understand that it's got to
be between the person and their doctor
and i shouldn't be involved in it
and i remember growing up being like
safe legal rare
now you've got one faction that's shout
your abortion pro-abortion
it's not pro-choice it's literally
pro-abortion michelle wolfe goes on
netflix
screaming you get an abortion and you
get an abortion and lena dunham says she
wish i had an abortion and i'm like
these videos man these are horrifyingly
disturbing videos for a moderate like
former democrat type personality i go to
my family and they're like
this is the most disgusting thing i've
ever seen we're the pro-choice people
not anymore there was a poll i saw
recently most people
agree with safe legal and rare most
people agree with a restriction on
wide margins yes margins yeah so who are
these fringe lunatics on social media
believing
that is what people like so phil is
correct
if there if if there is a move to the
supreme court to overturn roe v wade
it's going to be because moderates back
off like
you're i'm not on your side you're crazy
it's like i i'm not going to stand next
to that lady
she can go on protest i'm not doing it
no i'll be over there you guys are nuts
that's the kind of thing it's a really
good example of what's happening there
is a fringe element
where they go on social media and they
constantly one-up each other with the
most insane psychobabble nonsense
and regular democrat voters aren't there
so these people on social media are
dictating what
nancy pelosi does to a certain degree
yeah i mean this is how
uh right and this but this is how the
the left is radicalized also
you know i mean now you've got like a
west virginia
you know upper middle class couple with
you know three kids
who are social justice warriors because
because they go on instagram
it's the craziest thing when i go to
like west virginia and i see the flags
and i'm like what are you doing
like you don't where do you live but
these people aren't leaving though i
read an article from the ap
the the people who are slightly more
woke are leaving west virginia
and they're going to the big cities
they're going to oakland and new york
and things like that so this is this is
this is the physical polarization good
that's why i said i think collapse is
inevitable
yeah red states will get redder blue
states will get bluer and then
eventually you're going to have someone
in new york
who's like going to run for office we're
getting to the point where you have a
congress person
who's screaming about how 1619 is fact
and these conspiracy queue lunatics
believe this country was founded in
1776.
can you believe it and then you're gonna
have the republican being like because
it was and the guy's gonna plot a cane
start whacking him and you know what
that leads to right right
so when you when you see that the
ideologies are so
completely broken right but we're there
already
it's just it hasn't happened yet it's
because i mean all the all the bricks
are in place well no no so
there's still a large portion of older
people who are like sitting there with
their feet up kind of like i don't know
you know i'm i don't understand what's
happening
but you look at the younger generations
that are being raised in this war
millennials gen x there's not so much in
it you know no no i mean this is what i
was just saying this the other day
gen x is like you guys i mean i'm gen x
right
you know but then millennials full scale
full-on
yeah gen z it is substantially more
they're they're very like internet-based
and so i don't know where gen alpha will
go but i think
when you raise people in this in in this
climate what's going to happen is
a millennial understands history of 1776
but then here's 1619. if their tribe
deem it so
they say okay 1619. but they still
understand
well there are history books but they're
this that or otherwise what happens when
you have these kids
jen alpha growing up where they only
know 16 19 from their parents
then they're like these people are are
conspiracy
lunatics who believe in some fringe
alternate history about benjamin
franklin like
he has nothing to do with anything he
wasn't he he's not who funded this
country
and then what happens when those two
people meet each other over a conflict
they can't even have a discussion over
the ground they stand on
when you when the united states gets
into a conflict with another country
we we don't necessarily have arguments
over like their country versus our
country and our histories
it's like resources versus resources or
the future of the countries
hey you need to trade agreement with us
because we want to use this this river
or this straight or whatever
well it's one reason why democracy
democracies don't fight each other
right because we we we feel like we need
to have conversations about first
principles
but you know we can't have conflicts
about it
what happens when you have the 100 red
states 100
blue states and you go to congress and
someone says
i hereby think that all guns should be
banned and the other side says i think
constitutional carry should be universal
those are like so i was reading about
gun control we talked about it a bit
this week
in the 80s most states were may issue
concealed carry permits meaning you
probably wouldn't get one
today there's like 20 something plus
states that are constitutional carry
texas just signed it
that means if you're a resident texas
you can just walk around with a gun you
can conceal it
constitutional right to do so that's a
much more extreme version than we than
where we were 40 years ago even for
conservatives
and the democrats now are nominating a
guy david chipman who's like i want to
ban all guns
that goes crazy he's nuts he's like any
semi-auto that takes any with a
detectable magazine that takes over 22
caliber so it's like
so like every single gun every rifle
sorry
okay so what people are saying is that
he's just a plant you know he's
he's expect an expendable faint yeah
in order to get the the next guy in and
the next out comes in we'll be alive
we're not gonna ban air 15
exactly but we will nfa them right so
here's what i'm saying the democrats are
at the point where for the past several
years they've been straight up
ban all guns i'm not kidding they they
they've actually advocated for
consistently
banning semi-automatic weapons that's
like every single handgun
all of them that's it that's every
almost every rifle
you have bolt actions lever actions
revolvers but it gets rid of like 80 90
of guns they just ban them and then you
have the conservatives who are like
constitutional carry and then you have
people like me who end up falling on the
2a side because it's freedom and i'm
like everybody should have a government
issued
barrett m82 with a box of a thousand i'm
kidding by the way
but but i've i've jokingly talked about
semi-jokingly
the department of gun services
guaranteeing the right to own a firearm
because it's in the constitution sure if
you want universal health care well we
have a right to bear arms so we get that
first
i digress the point is the democrats are
are to the
as extreme as possible the conservatives
are getting
i wouldn't say extreme but
in a sense i don't want to say extreme
because being like
do your thing as the constitution
dictates i wouldn't call that extreme i
would call that foundational
but it is very i think conservatives are
going from yelling stop
to actually putting their foot down and
say okay we're going to stop
that's why the desantis bill is
important yeah because
instead of just you know bitching and
moaning
about big tech censorship it's something
where are the rest of the red states
this is i mean this is this is a problem
this is a this is a huge problem and
and i hope it's an indica i hope it lets
people know
about the dire nature of the situation
there every only florida everybody do
this tell your friends
your state if you're in a red state you
call your politicians and you say
please just do everything desantis is
doing
just there you go we're done uh i will
say the tennis bill is good on social
media censorship but
i'm i'm told the abbott one is better so
so follow the texas social media because
of ken paxton
who's great yeah so i guess in texas it
actually treats this is what i was told
by alan bakari that it treats the the
social networks like common carriers
right so it's like a phone company now
florida doesn't which means it'll be
very difficult to enforce a lot of what
they do hence they're being sued
so um but i'm talking like
constitutional carry and
uh social media rights and stuff like
that just desantis
you know do that stuff yeah and and i
mean the other got a call you got to
call and tell them
right the other aspect of this too is uh
is to make sure
in florida at least we've got cities and
municipalities
that are really excited now i know my
you know the mayor of miami is just
excited as as can be about bringing
more people into miami well he's got to
do this in a responsible way
so as not to bring in you know he wants
to make miami the new hub of big tech
okay that's great you're going to bring
a thousand social justice warriors in
from you know from silicon valley you
know you're not going to win again
if that's what you do i got a better one
i'm going to start hiring i'm hiring
people and making them all to move to
west virginia
so it's like we're hiring we're we're
hiring and we need to hire like a ton of
people but you got to live in the middle
of nowhere and hey west virginia is
paying people like 12 grand to move
there yep
so it's a great opportunity yeah and
there's a bunch of tax incentives
so it's like here you go you know but i
get a lot of people don't want to
necessarily move to west virginia they
want to go to texas sure and i'm like
well you know look texas is cool
and i get it because west virginia is
not moving fast enough i mean i have
friends who work in dc who are
considering west virginia
as a place where you can commute right
you can absolutely commute and if you
know maybe you'll
you'll go into the office two days a
week three days a week
it's absolutely doable well that's one
of the problems is that parts of west
virginia are turning blue
they're almost blue because dc people
are moving it's
it's hilarious so uh the the eastern
part of west virginia is now
like 47 democrat in
in one particular county because it's dc
dc workers who moved here
for freedom it's really funny because
like you know like neighborhoods apps
and stuff
you can really tell who the city people
are when they're complaining about like
animals and bears and like
gunshots going off and you're like you
should not be living here
but but there was a story that uh ap
reported mentioned that they're actually
losing more people uh
the people who are like lefty pro union
anti-gun are like i just can't stand
this it's so weird
and creepy and wrong and they're leaving
and i'm like opportunity guys
sure you know if you want to live in a
big city it smells like sour milk
and you can't do anything you go ahead
do with my blessing
you want to go in the mountains but that
also speaks to an awareness on their
side i mean you know
we're we've been talking about this
conflict and we think about it a lot and
talk about a lot okay
but the other guys even if they're not
talking about it
it enters their consciousness i think
everybody should move to west virginia
everybody the world no no no no i'm
talking about like people who are
who are paying attention all of india
moves i mean
i think literally you could fit all of
the people in the world into like
houston or something if they were
stacked like shoulder to shoulder oh
okay some ridiculous thing like that it
would like well no no it's bigger than
that but like
very little space no no i'm saying like
the people who are fleeing minneapolis
for instance
the people who are fleeing california uh
don't vote for democrats if you're going
to support the local politics but
like people should start setting up
industry and i've got places i've got
very little
for years i'm telling people to move to
red states you know florida texas where
i mean wherever
and i'm just i you you hear the same
things oh i can't i've got this reason
i've got that reason why
okay at some point it's probably going
to get bad enough for you to do it
this is the way i explained it like
there's there's a house
and there's a small fire in the garage
and they're like yeah i know there's a
fire there but i think i'll be fine and
you're like
at a certain point the fire's gonna
spread to the kitchen and then you're
gonna be sitting there
and if it spreads to the door you're
trapped anybody that has a fire in their
house and doesn't take
immediate emergency evasive action is a
[ __ ]
and look what's happening with people
who live in san francisco yep
the if you're a conservative you live in
san francisco i'm sorry i got it
i lived there for five years you left i
left there you go
there's human waste all over the ground
when i lived there
it was it was clean it was clean what
years were you there
um i was there um i was there
i guess early 2000s and uh yeah early
2000s
and and in the late 90s a little bit too
um but i i didn't want to be surrounded
by crazy people
people pooping all over the street i was
in the mission
right there i was on mission i was on
mission and then i was in nob hill
before
i loved that area i was over there too
yeah and and it was look i mean it was
great it was
it was great but the city collapsed the
same way
that new york collapsed which is that
the middle class
disappeared and the middle class
overlaps with the creative class too so
when the interesting people leave
and they can no longer afford to live
there i mean
first the families go and then the
people who have no families but don't
make a lot of money
and do you know play music and you know
cultural life things when they can no
longer afford to live in the city
you've got very poor and very rich and
it's boring and the city falls apart
and you know people are saying new york
is going to come back no
no it may be clean and safe well the
future
you know but it's not going to be fun
the rats are desperate
and so there's been rat packs running
around the city
so rats used to just eat the refuse it
was easy there was always
always waste once the people disappeared
the rats had to
go out and start fighting there's like a
video of a rat fighting a pigeon and
they're like both trying to eat each
other
well look you've got you know what how
many rats are in new york do you think
millions tens of millions tens of
millions and there was
and humans were constantly throwing
garbage on the ground for rats to eat
enough for the rats and the pigeons to
sustain a certain level of population
humans all disappeared now all of a
sudden the rats no food pigeons no food
they start fighting each other there's
like a video of someone getting attacked
by a squirrel too like a
squirrel's desperate like biting people
yeah and you get bit by that you gotta
go get your rabies shots sure
numerous shots you want to live there by
all means
you do with my blessing i'm going to go
out in the middle of the woods and you
know
i i went out i went out today and i
grabbed like 30 or 40 cicadas
in like 10 minutes just chuck them into
the chicken like a nice stew
no i'm not gonna eat bugs off the ground
get parasites you get the chickens
yeah chickens ate them up gobbled them
up hey it's like i don't gotta buy
chicken food this month
we got all the cicadas just it's crazy
it's like i go i
i walk along the edge of the property
collect in like 10 minutes like 30 40
cicadas
an hour later it's usually an hour later
i go back out same thing
skaters are all back chickens eat uh
just chicken feet so uh there's a little
egg laying layer
is it a protein meal okay these bugs
they grass okay so
an insect can replace you know for for a
chicken
uh uh you know cicada is like a treat oh
man oh yeah
yeah they go nuts they love mealworms
but they'll they're omnivores they'll
eat anything they grass
they just they they literally grass yeah
it's funny it's funny when you like feed
them grass through the through the wall
of like the coop and they're just like
freaking out trying to get it
yeah they love it it's like spaghetti
like they slurp it up it's become a
thing i never thought i mean you know
whatever i played played music lived in
new york whatever i never knew that i
would have multiple friends with who
owned chickens
yeah that was not a thing that i
expected in my life dude city life is is
whack
it's it's i thought it was like the only
way to go
for the first half of my life yeah but
communications changed it
now people can work remote now we got
satellite internet now
so when i was you know wanting to set up
a show i'm like we need good internet so
we want to be in a city
i was it was very difficult to internet
here it took us like six seven months i
think like a
yeah yeah so we're in the middle of
nowhere to get
we we had really bad internet uh
and then in order to get like a business
level internet we had to
and covered later really expensive
yeah yeah it's probably like 10 or 20
times the cost of normal internet
or maybe even 30 times the cost of
normal internet i don't know i think
cities get a bad rap
um you know cities get a bad rap these
days especially from
from folks who are you know on the right
or folks who have kind of recently left
cities
because um because they used to be
really cool they used to be a lot
different
and it was prior to the social media age
it was when you know there's something
special that happens with
a bunch of people you know
in approximately in the same place
music yeah creativity yeah yeah and but
but it's
it's homogeneous it it it made
everything
boring in the same so it used to not be
yeah i know
you know uh well i often ask people when
was the last so we have christmas music
music every year
when was the last christmas song written
1998
1994. all i want for christmas is yeah
but prior to that it was what like 1968
and then 50s and we still listen to the
same songs
it's culture homogenized and then
stagnated so maybe this is good maybe
maybe this like
city evacuation or whatever is going to
be so we need
new we need new cities we need like
tunnels for the traffic so that we can
walk around outside without looking
around
getting hit by cars brake dust elon
built them like that we need
vertical farms so that we can grow our
food within the cities like on street
corn like
entire city blocks dedicated to giant
indoor farms
there's no reason why a bunch of cool
people can't move
to a small town and create
what you know functionally was
everything pretty
decent about a city people got to move
out to west virginia that'd be so cool
and then make make we'll call it cool
world i know solar roads aren't
super effective because they get dirty
they don't work at all but man there
must be a way
there will be there will be a way no i
think i remember the solar roads thing
and i think it's just like a child's
dream like a solar park they're like if
all the roads are solar panels then
we'll have all this power and it's like
i don't i i get it there's roads and
they absorb sunlight but like
what like you're driving big rigs on
these things they're gonna break
and they're gonna get covered in dirt
and snow and they're not gonna work it's
going to refract the self clean
it doesn't but but they'll they're going
to crack under the pressure it depends
on what you make them out not
like just build solar panels why why
why not just put the solar panel on the
side of the road why put the car on top
of it
because it's in the because it's like
pollution no it's
the road itself is already there put it
put line line the highway with solar
panels
don't make the cars drive on honestly
you're right i'd rather have no idea
what you guys
there was like a viral there's a viral
video about solar roads where they were
like if we replace all of the roads with
solar panels and drive on those instead
we'll power the country and it's like
the cars are going to break them they're
made out of like double reinforced glass
so they don't really
they can handle it's literally pressure
no they can't what literally happened
was the cars broke them
theoretically they they could in the
future they're just they're in prototype
stage right now
this was this was ten years but i think
the road should be underground anyway
so the point is why not just put the
solar panels
over the road huh because it's pollution
what do you mean it's political it's
like
it's like sight pollution it pollutes
the environment you can't see past it
dude it blocks it just do nuclear and
you can ha
and you can have it right beautiful sky
you don't have to
here's what you do you make and you
cover all roads are covered
tunnels with solar panels on top i also
want to put
power lines with screens inside yeah
so that when you know when you're
driving in the tunnel you can watch tv
you can see what you know you can do
twitter you could do whatever you want
yeah if we could put that we gotta we
gotta we gotta read these super chats
if you haven't already you you can do us
a favor by smashing the like button
because it really does matter
and uh sharing the show and the video
with your friends just to help spread
the word and maybe
have an impact on culture in a way that
will make us a bit more optimistic
and don't forget to go to timcast.com
become a member we have another vlog
coming up tomorrow over at cast castle
on youtube so make sure you check that
out because we had a blast the past
weekend
all right let's see justin o'toole says
tim please invite thunderfoot onto tim
cash to talk about ufos
that sounds fun make 1984 fiction again
said could there be a sign of optimism
do uh uh army ad is currently ratioed
five to five five point five thumbs up
133 thousand thumbs down wow
yikes not surprising james says harambe
was an inside job
uh that's a fact it was a guy who worked
for the zoo who shot him
you think the kid was a plant it was a
doll
it was like a crisis actor yeah yeah
remember when
the the meme about hillary clinton
harambe tweeted i have information that
will
uh seeking detroit is pouring one out
for the homie rip harambe i am a gorilla
much love we we i can't believe we
messed this up we should have made a
harambe shirt i am harambe yeah and it
should have had the
you know yeah i think we still can yeah
i am harambe yeah harambe is eternal
come back next week did the same show
yeah we have the i am a gorilla shirt
meme okay
so it was a perfect opportunity for
i wonder if i i got to say something
weird going on with gorillas you know
what i mean
there's the ape stronger together thing
mm-hmm that's
together strong apes together strong
there's there's harambe there's the uh
uh
ishmael book alex jones saying actually
yeah we got these gorillas here
what's this it's the it's just all these
gorillas oh you have ishmael right there
why oh
this is my life tim look at that ishmael
the book shout out to the gorilla
ishmael there's the psychic gorilla have
you ever read this book before
no that's where that all came from the
alex jones meme oh
okay i'm a gorilla it's a pretty cool
book actually i'll bet
all right hey yo gang says huge
huge fan tim i'm part of the tim cast
members only and i have one question is
there any way i could get an autograph
so we actually as part of the new site
are building an auction system
for a variety of reasons so the live
events we wanted to start doing in
february and then there's some like
legal paperwork stuff that's
put us on hiatus we want to do it soon
uh what we're going to do is we're going
to do 10 first come first serve for
everybody who's giving 25
everyone at the membership level of 25
or more will see a post where it's like
boom tickets are now now available
because we're going to do events
every friday night so it'll be from like
10 after the show ends until like
midnight
and physical events physical events here
yep with like dj's
music and it'll be like 20 to 30 people
per week who are allowed to come and
hang out so happening
oh yeah in the old days like a happening
a legit party or a hoot nanny
that's right and so half the tickets
will be first come first served
that means there's literally going to be
people like sitting there like
refreshing constantly like i want to get
a ticket you know because
you know but then we're gonna have
auction tickets so we're trying to
balance meritocracy
with access and it's not easy because
it's only a finite amount
but in that we're gonna be able to
auction off stuff autographed shirts
posters etc um and then people
when they come to the live events we're
going to taste ian's amazing bread oh
it's going to be good
yeah we're actually going to make some
cricket bread yeah that's the that's on
the horizon yeah
we have a bag of cricket flour so um
there's no gluten in it which means
we're going to need to probably mix it
with regular flour
and then we're going to make a tomorrow
we'll fill it with cricket bread i mix
okay
cricket bread i'm sure it's delicious i
got no problem eating bugs
all right let's see where we at what do
we got here
pnw paranormal paranormalish says
super serious question tim castro does
anyone play world of warcraft classic
if so what do you think the best race
class combo is and why is it troll mage
you're incorrect good sir
um night elf druid night elf druid yeah
i mean druids are legit
i'm always down for rogue does so much
damage
you know i like human rogue is because
of in classic you have the um
the perception so it's easier to see
other
rogues and i like i like alterac valley
i always like
shadow meld because you can get up and
go to the bathroom and just like
you know stealth for a little while oh
yeah shadow melts great to answer your
question yes tim and i were actually
playing
a couple of minutes ago you wanna know
what's really crazy so i started playing
world of warcraft i think like 2005.
legit og and so i remember in the early
days this is what 15 years ago
alteric valley it when when you're
playing as
uh as either faction really i i would
play as alliance and everyone would be
like no the horde's better whatever man
so the the alliance towers in
in alterate valley there's you as a
rogue
i would just hide behind the wall and
then i would sneak up it's
frozen aren't familiar basically capture
the flag yeah the enemy team comes and
then they they click the flag and then
there's a timer it's like 10 seconds
if they can affect if they are untouched
for 10 seconds the flag switches teams
if they can hold it for a certain amount
of time they destroy the tower
the rogues are effectively invisible
it's called stealth you can't see them
right
so 15 years ago i'm playing and that was
my strategy i would hide and i'm very
smart and i just wait
and they would be sitting there thinking
they've won at the very last second
i would switch it back erasing all their
progress right
world of warcraft world of warcraft
classic comes out
and i'm like i wonder if the same
strategy still works on these people
you know 15 years later and it does
people never
it's amazing i'm like you'd think you'd
learn after a point
but you know what it is a lot of these
people probably came back to the game
from the same old
because i had played uh worlds of
draenor i played legion
and um i played a little bit of uh
shadowlands and then
and so i'm like i'm used to the game so
going back to classic
i'm familiar with the game and these
people keep falling for the same tricks
it's the same thing about people setting
their cups on the ground i think they've
been doing it for tens of thousands of
years they just keep kicking over those
cups
just got to put your cup up on a table
don't set it on the ground humans do
human stuff man they do
it's like like it's human behavior it's
real thing
yeah anyway uh let's read super chats
name changer says hi i'm common sense a
level four bio lab that studies corona
bet viruses one mile away from the
epicenter of the pandemic
and democrats accept the chinese said
it's not relevant i knew this a year ago
why now are you accepting it morons not
tim and friends
so like i said i got a question
i'll make the one point real quick if
you have a bio bio lab and an open wet
market
and they're like where did the virus
come from i'll be like this one's got no
security
the simple solution is the no security
one you add in all the new information
and the reports they never released
changes narrative sure let me ask a few
weeks ago when we saw the uh
the the kind of first negative stories
about bill gates coming out
which stories um in regards to the
divorce and then you were like okay he's
you know he's engaged in this bad bad
behavior
he's done this and that all of a sudden
you know um bill gates for the first
time
was kicked down a peg um
i'm thinking like was this part of um
look
they knew that they were going to roll
this out this didn't roll out
immediately just like the story
this this particular story this
particular story is like
what three days old i mean little brick
by brick by brick by brick getting
to fouchy yeah and then fauci comes out
and says well you know
so we're talking almost a week now where
this story has been softened
to where you can talk about it and this
is what's what's going on i mean this
this
you know it's a it's a it's an info op
you know when you
when you stagger the the stories like
this knowing that you're going to get
this result so i'm
i'm wondering what the next shoot drop
will be number one
number two is i'm wondering does the
let's say demystification
of um of bill gates
have anything to do you know prior to
this thing having
anything to do with it it all leads to
xi jinping
transforming into some kind of mutant
demon
zombie because yeah like like voltron
yeah like other one guy will like join
his right arm the other guy will come in
his left arm
zombie voltron zombo
kofit 21 what's happening oh
it's yeah okay he's too big i think it's
the same thing with where hi
hillary railroaded bernie sanders in
2016. it was
so obvious but the media like just was
like
people were just like drool coming down
and it was the same way with this this
bio lab thing i think it was obvious to
every sentient
it just seemed like common sense right
it was it was just a matter of time i
wonder why now it's falling apart
maybe it's because this thing is
basically over i mean i saw probably
i saw a friend of mine tweeting a photo
from a lower manhattan
uh um uh you know
clothing store no mask like okay you
know what this thing's over
yep you know if in lower manhattan
you're walking around without
shopping without a mask this thing is
over so maybe now we're just
sort of in the mop up yeah all right we
got green doors
please discuss u.s farmers being offered
money to destroy their crops or be
refused farming subsidies if they refuse
so this is called fallowing a field and
it's been around forever
yeah yeah yeah so so there's rumors
going around where people are like the
government's telling us
we have to shut down our farms otherwise
we don't get our subsidies
so then we're broke so people think
there's going to be a food shortage
why are they doing it exactly they're
being paid to not grow crops
yeah i i interviewed a bunch of farmers
about this i can't remember all the all
the details though
this was years ago but they they'll so
they'll rotate where like the government
will say we'll pay you
whatever you would have made to not grow
crops is that like just to
to limit the supply to keep the value
the cost up or something
i think basically that's the that's the
the main idea i don't know the details
either
rampton says michael knowles book on
pre-order or whatever
oh yeah speechless no no but you see it
they're just getting lower and lower
effort
come on man i demand high quality all
right jay neighbor says hello tim cast
has now been heard throughout the
continental united states
unfortunately unfortunately it is all by
one one
fat and now apparently old truck driver
from dubuque old
truth hurts tim thanks thought you would
like to know
we actually had someone i i mentioned
that like the people who watched listen
it's like a regular guy
like a truck driver a fat truck driver
driving through the buick or something
or from dubuque and then some guy was
like hey that's me
that's crazy i love our reach the throne
says you don't need to regulate big tax
just enforce the existing rules
the private ownership argument doesn't
hold up when you look at the decision of
alabama v marsh from the u.s supreme
court
all right well there you go
that uh the one free man says covet
rockets falling from the sky the uyghurs
china has proven to be incompetent and
irresponsible
the lies we tell incur a debt to the
truth the debt will always come due
covet was china's chernobyl yikes yeah
the rocket falling from the sky remember
that they're like it might land on new
york
oh wow yeah i don't want to live in
there i mean
someone you may know says tim developers
create public spaces because many
municipalities
have set a maximum floor space a
building can have however you can exceed
that maximum by how much public space
you create
really yes tax incentives there you go
good to know
that's right good to know so that i mean
that concept though or our understanding
of of
the rules around that comes from the
company town
you know in in the wild west and then
you know and elsewhere in the country
when you've got
a corporation a corporation basically
owns a town do you have any rights there
is the company um you know is is
does can the government call the all the
shots in a place
those still exist like the frack fields
and i think north dakota sure
they like build a city for the employees
it's crazy wow
yeah and in alaska too i had a friend
who worked in alaska and there's like
a town that exists just for one company
and
like there's one big communist looking
like block house
because they're not gonna build a bunch
of houses they need to house their
employees
and there's like one store it's i don't
know it's kind of cool antarctica sounds
pretty fun there's like 10 people there
or something in the winter
sounds good yeah jimmy russell says
tim i think the libertarian position on
private company speech relies on
enforcing 230.
the moment someone is censored the
company should lose its 230 protection
becoming legally liable for all speech
on the service
but that's regulation libertarians are
like nah also you got to define
censorship because if i look at your
post
and allow it i'm still censoring you i'm
acting as the censor saying yes or no
you don't you don't have to shut it down
in order for it to be censorship you can
also allow it
doug phelps says tim you are
generalizing 800 000 cops there are bad
cops in bad leadership
stop painting cops as bad or all we will
have are bad cops
right and as i've pointed out i defended
the police all throughout the last year
until the people voted in the system
and the good cops quit or should say
many of the good cops quit
and then the ones who remained are
willing to lick the feet of bill de
blasio
and whitmer and other corrupt
politicians so i'm not going to call
them good cops
they have a choice to leave you know
what needs to happen
ron desantis and you know maybe greg
abbott
some other guys should get together and
say okay we will go and we will buy out
your contracts if you are a cop if
you're a good cop
in a blue state or a blue city christine
is doing this
and bring them in that would be really
south dakota as a recruit i i think
they're
i think they're doing this i think
that's them recruiting uh the cops who
are quitting to come to south dakota
where they're not
ideal yeah that's a great idea i thought
you were gonna say like ronda sanders
and abbott should combine their power
rings together
mm-hmm and then you know wonder
governor's power is a sequel right
be yeah yeah i mean so xi jinping
becomes communist voltron and then like
yeah no no no abbott and santos
combine their rings together yes jesus
and then activate their powers wonder
governors
[Laughter]
jacob dauben spec says wait if we're in
the prequels does that mean that joe
budden is jar jar
only if jar jar is secretly a sith lord
as that oh i've heard
the conspiracy theories jar jar was a
sith huh
yeah he was the real villain of the
movie he's like a star wars joke and
then he just everything just goes
everybody knows that star wars is just
anti-empire propaganda
true that's true like they call like
like these leftists call the u.s
the empire and the imperialists it
probably like the empire never
about the empire didn't even really call
itself the empire oh good point
yeah it was probably called like united
states we don't have to do federation
it's the empire no no but what they
called it themselves
the empire oh like i'm just kidding like
vader is like literally my new empire
it was the republic and then it became
the empire it's basically rome it's it's
it's supposed to be rome in the movie i
think i'd like to see a series that
is like not propaganda against the uh
the the uh the elites yeah we need to
take care of there's like
there's some really interesting like uh
fan writings about the jedi being
ineffective
authoritarian and religious zealots
imposing their will with with force like
literally the force
against you know people who disagree
with them intervening and politically
a lot of people have written this yeah
yeah yeah so you think about like the
the the
the the first movie with the trade
federation and naboo
why were two knights with laser swords
sent in
for a negotiation between a trade
dispute so it's like that's that's
and so that's actually a part of the
movie i recently watched the first one
again
and when the trade federation is like
the the jedi were sent here like what
why
yeah seriously imagine if someone sent
like two high-ranking like you know like
seal team six was sent in to negotiate a
trade dispute with some con co
some countries they'd be like uh what do
you this is really weird
yeah the jedi were nuts man they're
religious zealots
i wanna we should make that short film
oh yeah so it'd be like it'd be like
yeah
vader is a disabled veteran war hero so
it'd be like if the u.s government was
negotiating a trade contract with google
and then like
mi6 showed up a couple of like every six
no no
no it would be like if uh there was a
port blockade in
in greece because a uh
like chinese vessel was trying to
negotiate a trade deal
so the us sends in seal team six to
negotiate
peace they'd be like nah
that's what it was that's what happened
and then that that actually triggered
the conflict they're like you know then
citizens like kill them they should
never have been involved
you know so they should have been
involved man
chris povoto says since tim keeps saying
he'll never run for an official office
position why not use this platform
and reach to reform section 230. there's
several guests
and supports to give input then submit
the papers for to congress
i mean we do talk about a lot we do
invite people on to talk about it and uh
didn't we just say uh congress and the
federal government is a dead end
local politics yep yeah you gotta go
local one by one the states will start
adopting the law
then eventually it'll be a huge conflict
it'll go to the supreme court and then
you'll get your answer
not that i trust the supreme court to be
honest do you see that video of clarence
thomas laughing
oh the best laugh yeah what a lot yeah
classic
i like the meme where it's like you know
you know the meme where the woman says
men only want one thing is disgusting
and then someone put the image of it's
the supreme court but everyone is
clarence thomas yes
correct yeah ben d says i agree with
david we are in the prequel we just
passed when natalie portman says this is
how liberty dies to thunderous applause
people are cheering for the system
burning yep yes
that's sad well it was a good run i
guess
no i think it was like 1900s when things
got real bad you know
the good thing is states the united
states the state's rights and the power
of the state because
no federal prohibition has ever really
worked that i can tell
they tried to prohibit alcohol they try
to prohibit weed if they try to prohibit
guns the states are just going to say
fu and do what they want anyway i like
that
well no i mean because traditionally the
states
i mean would that if they did i mean
traditionally the states end up buckling
because they're all taking money from
the federal government
in some way you know i mean the states
don't want to be responsible for
you know just a lot of the stuff that
the federal government uh pays for
yeah and this is how and this is how
they um you know this is how they get
this is how the federal government so
the left gets everything they want in
the states
federal funny money yeah what's
happening now is
before the pandemic the blue states were
in serious trouble
now they're all getting bailed out
because of covet another surplus
all right aaron malnauer says enjoy your
show and your guests rock
aaron molinaro for president 2024 a
common man for uncommon times
together we will win back america for
ian and america i will order an audit of
the fed yes i will mandate
constitutional studies in all public
schools
i like that you have a platform yes
bought at the fed jerome morrow says
ian's been too calm tonight
what do you think about getting rid of
the federal reserve and then replacing
gold with graphene as the global reserve
medium
oh interesting concept wow yeah great
being scarce
and it and it could be valuable that we
bypass
the uh the money system completely and
just have a resource-based economy
that's based on elections what does that
mean resource graphene
what's a resource-based economy um where
you use
you know i mean you would need a total
retrofit of the economy you need fusion
power to
what is it what is a resource-based
economy like um you use electricity as
your resource your main resource to
atomically print water and food but what
do you mean i don't know locally
but we we we can do that can what so
what's our economy based off of them
this current economy yeah
um fiat so wait
so i don't understand what you're saying
yeah it means faith it's faith
economy you print as much money as you
want so you're passing around you're
saying people would generate electricity
and then what trade batteries
no you would trade electricity yeah yeah
you could charge each other's batteries
and stuff like that so how would you
quantify the electricity
i guess you could measure it so then you
trade like amp hours
yeah probably so you'd call like one an
amp so you'd have a bank account with
like 10
amps in it yeah you'd have a battery
you'd have a battery there would be no
more need for banks
you just have batteries that are charged
or discharged so you could make your own
energy
i think so you could like ride a bike
and then generate
that that leaves individual power
because you don't want the state to like
be charging everyone's batteries for
them you want the individual
that's a very private thing that no
that's kind of cool though you don't
come behind
imagine if it was like based on energy
you could literally ride a bike for an
hour charge a battery and then go to the
store and click it in
and then transfer your energy to the
grid and then get an apple phone i love
that guy he rides his bike
eight hours a day and powers my house
everyone loves that guy because he does
all the work nobody would nobody would
say that but you could you'd walk up and
go to your friend's house and be like
you got
some sugar i can borrow here and you
click you click your battery in and send
them some of your power or whatever
or probably be an app and it would
transfer from your storage in your house
you could go to someone's house
use your battery to power their atomic
printer to get food at their house
imagine if you could get like a solar
panel on your house which generated so
much power it put money back in the grid
and they gave you money instead
that's literally how it works yep yeah i
don't like money
well money is just a number for a trade
medium i don't like relying on money i
guess i should say
can you imagine the depravity
the societal depravity that would
accompany
all of these different things you know
by the time society got to
you know by the time civilization got to
the point where we're doing this and
we're
you know uh you know trading energy you
know on on on thumb drives as
you know for food um you know i mean
just imagine the depravity imagine the
state of humanity i constantly think
about how we can transition
without a fallout without like losing
a quarter of the population to poverty
or to
well look you know the way the woke
stuff is going
all of the high-tech stuff is not going
to be you know possible
it's just not going to be possible you
know i mean i i think i think the plan
needs to be hey let's force
harvard to hire you know only
you know only people of color force them
to do it force them to do it
like you know well the fact that it's
racial justice the fed is getting woke
and i'm here for it
yeah get well go bro yes all right here
we go enjoy coca-cola light says
star wars was written by the victors of
wars of course vader is depicted as some
evil madman
consider the story told by the empire
coming out as the victors
that's right that's absolutely right his
armor looked way cooler than
than that all black things we should
write it we should we should make it
like the real with the real events yeah
the real history of
of of of star wars vader's like trying
to convince people and vader won't be
like this big
looming demonic figure with a red yeah
he's like five nine
and he's got some cyber components and
he's like kids he's already he's a
father and he's not going
no no he has he has his two kids he has
luke and he's and they're kidnapped by
religious extremists oh wow yeah he's a
warrior aunt and
uncle were like religious extremists yep
they weren't really as ant
no he escaped the religious extremism
and went and and you know
and got to learn and then realized they
were corrupt mil you know
religious extremists and he's like he's
struggling he struggles to breathe you
know he's got like a breathing machine
people like him and he's really nice
your mother did this to me
yeah yeah see it's all propaganda we
should make it we'll make like a
10-minute short film
it could be a good 10-minute short film
it wouldn't be called the empire
it would be called like the galactic
federation and it would be like
people from a desert planet taking a
cargo ship and blowing up a military
base
and you'd see like the families crying
and
you'd have the emperor who was
disfigured from an assassination attempt
when
the jedi tried to kill him and he's like
we lost 1 million
372 lives that day when religious
extremists blew up a military base
you know like building hospitals and
things yeah yeah
that's right yeah we should totally do
it all right let's see we'll do a couple
more
clifton stock says west virginia pays
and work for tim pool what positions are
available
we are doing commissions for many docs
which is contract work
we're looking for journalists and we've
gotten a lot of submissions and
you know with all due respect the ones
we've been through it's just
like we need actual journalists with
experience
and it's not particularly easy to you
know trying to quality control and get
the best of the best so it's very
difficult
we need a av tech full-time
for setting up new shows we're going to
be setting up like a gaming lab
and the paranormal show and stuff like
that we need
uh camera operators full-time and uh
yeah along with those skill requirements
if you are interested in sending a
resume or something make sure you send
actual samples of work
i don't really care all that much about
resumes and if you
you know skate scoot bike blade whatever
pogo stick those are all big advantages
and we are
also if someone has a drone pilot's
license camera opera
camera operator with a drone pilot
license absolutely we are looking for
that too
and they're all on location jobs in the
maryland west virginia area there you go
pioneer smoke houses says ian money is
just a means of bridging the gaps
between wants and needs
it's true until you can print as much of
it as you want and then it becomes a
weapon
as well blip squeaks since i'm
disappointed you didn't seize the
opportunity to leave
ian's picture for the whole night it was
hysterical when you switch it can we
show that one more time is that still up
let me see oh hold on sorry let me move
over to that yep it's still there thank
you lydia
it's so weird he looks very tired
everyone
that's a crazy image i haven't seen it
yet it's so weird
i'll show you i'll show it to you after
it's hilarious how does it happen that's
so funny
all right everybody it's friday night
it's party time if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to the
show
and if you are a true fan of tim cast
irl and the conversations we have
sharing posting the episodes every night
just put them on your facebook or
twitter wherever you can
and maybe your shadow band or whatever
but sharing is the most powerful thing
we can do so
it really really helps us out and makes
sure that we can hire more people and do
more work
and hopefully we'll permeate the fake
news ecosystem and get more people to
realize what's happening
you can follow us on facebook
facebook.com tim cast irl share our
videos just click the little share
button super easy
and on instagram at
instagram.comtimcast.irl and you can
follow me
at timcast basically everywhere dave you
want to shout out any
posts or websites sure go to my website
all the stuff is there
d-a-v-e-r-e-a-b-o-i dot com
uh follow me on twitter daverboy and
uh right on thank you it's great your
insight man that was really fun thanks
thank you it was a pleasure you guys can
always follow me at ian crossland.net
and ian crossland on social media and
check out some of my music on amazon
music
um i think it's on spotify i itunes and
and the like and uh let me know what you
think
i think will of the people will finally
be on uh itunes and spotify excellent
yeah that's awesome and then i'm in the
corner pushing buttons as always you
guys are more than welcome to follow me
on twitter i am at sour patch lids and i
am trying to outpace
sour patch kids for followers it's a
challenge i'm hoping to get there soon
make sure you check out youtube.com cast
castle
because we're gonna have a vlog up
tomorrow where we're setting up the new
3d printers today
andreas was working on was it petg is
that it's called polyethylene tetra
glycol i think okay something like that
i don't know and it's like a
it's printing amazing i'm impressed the
abs was warping pla is way too weak
we tried carbon fiber but the extruder
is too low of temperature because you
know like 290
okay and we were working at like 250 but
it was working until
the plate was too cold and it popped off
so we're very disappointed it looks cool
we got a cnc machine too excellent yes
it's going to be a lot of fun so make
sure you check out sure yeah
youtube.comcastcastle tomorrow at 9am
and we'll see you all then bye guys
you